il voulait faire une démonstration de
force Jean-Luc Mélenchon en tête de
cortège pour la marche contre la vie
chère et l'inaction climatique retrouve
le sourire une journée test dans la rue
à la veille d'une semaine cruciale nous
allons avoir une semaine hors du commun
qui commence aujourd'hui et la puissance
de notre marche est un appui à la
mobilisation des salariés notamment
celle qui va avoir lieu en grève
générale le 18
si Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est galvanisé
ses partisans
les revendications de la marche retraite
à 60 ans augmentation des salaires et
taxation des super profits par exemple
dominent pourquoi les riches ont gagné
la planète comptait alors 12 millions de
millionnaires en dollars américains
aujourd'hui estimation du Crédit Suisse
ils sont 62 millions cinq fois plus en 8
ans 5 millions de plus en un an en
France ils étaient 400 000 ils sont 2
millions 8 cette fois plus
mais non
d'euros par an il gagne 500000 euros
mais 50000 euros par an c'est un smicard
pour un PDG de
il gagne 400 fois mais pour un PDG du
CAC 40 50000 euros par mois c'est le
SMIC cher ami les millionnaires sont
dans la petite pointe de la pyramide 62
millions d'individus soit un peu plus de
1% des adultes qui contiennent 48% de la
richesse mondiale il y a 20 ans ce
chiffre était de 35% et puis vous voyez
à la base la grosse base c'est près de 3
milliards d'individus qui détiennent un
peu plus de 1% de la richesse mondiale
vous gagnez combien par mois vous êtes
une plus grosse salaire bien sûr on est
un ministre gagne entre 14 et 15000
euros quelque chose comme ça
c'est le net
quand on observe l'actualité de ces sept
derniers jours je me pose une question
est-ce que un dimanche soir comme
celui-ci vous dites parfois ce serait
bien rentré à l'Élysée pour repartir aux
affaires
non je me dis c'est pas facile d'être à
l'Elysée c'est pas simple et ça n'est
jamais simple pour quiconque qu'est-ce
que ça nous dit des inégalités en France
que nous sommes malgré tout l'un des
pays les plus égalitaires du monde où
l'un des moins inégalitaires le chiffre
le plus frappant c'est celui du
patrimoine médian 128.000 euros ça veut
dire qu'un Français sur deux possède
plus de 128.000 euros et pour l'autre
moitié c'est moins 128000 c'est une fois
et demi le patrimoine médian d'un
Américain Balenciaga a confirmé la
sortie imminente d'un sac paquet de
chips c'est même une collaboration
officielle avec la marque de chips lays
le sac est en cuir il est zippé c'est
marqué Balenciaga dedans deux
écologistes du mouvement just stopoil
ont jeté de la soupe à la tomate sur les
tournesols de Van Gogh pour dénoncer
l'impact des énergies fossiles sur le
climat la sécurité a mis du temps à
arriver la toile estimée à 84 millions
d'euros semble souiller mais
heureusement elle est en réalité
protégée par une plaque de verre
qu'est-ce qui a le plus de valeur l'art
ou la vie êtes-vous plus préoccupé par
la protection d'une peinture ou la
protection de notre planète
depuis quelques mois des actions
similaires se multiplient dans les
musées européens à Florence devant ce
tableau de Botticelli
à Londres avec ce paysage recouvert
d'une scène de nature saccagée ou encore
au Louvre ou un homme entré en fauteuil
roulant avait entarté la Joconde en
invoquant là aussi la protection de
l'environnement un bonheur de pouvoir
transformer la vie des gens c'est un
bonheur de pouvoir peser sur le destin
du monde mais on peut être aussi heureux
en faisant du cinéma ou en faisant tout
ce qui peut changer une part de la vie
en commun et ce que je trouve
le plus démonstratif c'est que le
bonheur n'est jamais plaisir solitaire
on peut pas jouir de son propre bonheur
tout seul enfermé le bonheur il est
forcément pour partager
je m'appelle
Albert j'habite la dernière dans la
vallée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand même de parler un peu plus
doucement ce qui est une personne sur le
plateau là-bas que vous pouvez pas voir
parce que il y a pas de caméra mais qui
est en train de dormir je pense que
notre émission est passionnant
il est gentil votre chien
il râle moins que des gens qui sont sur
ce plateau d'habitude
c'est l'invité le plus sage que nous
ayons eu depuis que l'émission depuis
que l'émission depuis que l'émission
existe parce que vous vous sentez vous
optimiste
peut-être pas tant que ça jamais
ça vous êtes une très grande journée
claire vous allez me faire dire des
trucs j'avais pas envie de dire
des choses que vous n'avez pas envie de
dire